que todo el mundo aguante añadan
gasolina fue el grito de aliento de los
tres activistas prodemocracia
hongkoneses antes de declararse
culpables por su papel en las protestas
existe la posibilidad de que me envíen a
prisión o yo en un futuro muy cercano
experimentar el primer encarcelamiento
de mi vida hoy este lunes joshua won
magnet shop e iván land aceptaron los
cargos de incitar una manifestación
frente a una estación de policía durante
las masivas protestas prodemocráticas
que se sucedieron durante meses el año
pasado en el territorio semi autonómico
el trío de destacados activistas fue
puesto en prisión preventiva hasta que
se dicte una sentencia el próximo 2 de
diciembre por la que enfrentan una pena
de hasta cinco años de cárcel tal vez
las autoridades desean que me quede en
la cárcel pero estoy convencido de que
ni los barrotes de la prisión y la
prohibición de las elecciones ni ningún
otro poder arbitrario nos impedirá el
activismo
el pasado junio beijing aprobó una ley
de seguridad nacional para hong kong en
respuesta a los meses de protestas
antigubernamentales la nueva norma es un
intento de silenciar las peticiones de
los hongkoneses
e incumple la obligación de china de
conceder al territorio un alto grado de
autonomía según los opositores no se
trata de una cuestión diplomática
apoyamos a los departamentos pertinentes
del gobierno de la región administrativa
especial para que cumplan con sus
deberes de acuerdo con la ley ya china
aceptó respetar la autonomía para la ex
colonia británica en 1997 pero los
críticos alegan que las constantes
detenciones están eliminando las
libertades de sus ciudadanos